la nueva cepa de coronavirus encontrada
en reino unido ha hecho saltar las
alarmas de todo el mundo pero que se
sabe de ella hasta el momento según el
gobierno británico es hasta un 70% más
contagiosa que la cepa original pero
estas fuentes señalan que ni es más
virulenta ni es más mortal y defienden
que las vacunas desarrolladas también
pueden combatirla
una postura que también defiende el
ministro de salud alemán
la nueva cepa es más transmisible la
buena noticia es que hasta ahora no
parece que cause un empeoramiento de la
enfermedad lo cual es importante y hasta
donde sabemos de esta cepa la vacuna aún
debería funcionar contra ello en varios
países como italia sudáfrica o países
bajos ya han registrado casos algo que
ha provocado un cierre masivo de
fronteras reino unido asegura que un 62
por ciento de los nuevos contagios en
londres pertenecen a esta cepa lo que ha
convertido a la capital británica en el
epicentro el propio ministro de salud
británico reconoció que la situación
está fuera de control para una ley de
spoilers desafortunadamente
nueva cepa del virus está fuera de
control tenemos que controlarla y la
única forma en que podemos hacerlo es
restringiendo el contacto social seis
causas las mutaciones son habituales en
los virus y esta no es la primera de
coronavirus en noviembre dinamarca tuvo
que sacrificar a miles de visones al
detectar otra el problema de la
detectada en reinounido es que llega en
un momento crítico en europa a sólo unos
días para empezar su programa de
vacunación